by the way a happy birthday I meant to
tell you that when you walked in uh oh
thanks last week was the big birthday do
you celebrate your birthday yeah Daryl
had a beautiful party for me it was
fantastic Stephen was there and Joni was
there and uh and all my friends my
family everybody it was cool it was
great are you looking at your age at all
and reflecting and saying I've done it
all I'm fine I'm I'm on the I'm on the
back nine it's okay I'm completely calm
about it or are you freaking the [ __ ]
out I'm not freaking out I'm I but there
is something going on I don't know what
it may be you know when you see that
you know when I just made this movie
about Harvest and and I watched it and
you know and everybody in it's gone I'm
the only one that's not gone
yeah I should tell people you know I
should tell people what you're talking
about I'm excited about this Neil
recorded on film when he made the album
Harvest which to me I think we're going
to be brought into the studio and
actually see you create one of the best
albums in the whole world Harvest it's a
[ __ ] mind-blowing album is that what
I'm gonna see when you release this uh
film
well you're going to see how we did it
and us doing it but it'll be other takes
not the takes you're used to right and
uh all the stuff I did in my barn and
then I did some of the you know with the
London Symphony Orchestra but we
recorded that we we filmed it when I
hear the orchestration you know a man
needs a maid one of my favorite songs he
ever wrote that's you on the piano but
then it builds I mean you did multiple
takes you didn't just right out of the
box do it the big problem was the timing
between me and the orchestra and the
conductor
so because of that
we did it a few times Maybe
five or six takes so when you did this
song you were sitting with the orchestra
in other words they were in the set wow
while you're playing the piano that's
we're all in there together it's all
there all everything you hear all
happened at once it all was the
conductor the
all this stuff
it's all there it was cool and it's
what's in the that's the movie and then
on the Same album you have Heart of Gold
I think the original version of it with
me on acoustic
without the band before the band
recorded it is in the Harvest Time album
and I would love to hear that because I
bet it's even better well it's it's more
basic you know and then look on this
album too Alabama
[Music]
you'll see Crosby and stills singing on
this song you brought him in for this
why did you bring him in you just said
this will work with these guys I I need
these guys to sing this because they can
sing I look forward to seeing this
Harvest project I really do want to see
how you put these songs together that to
me would be as interesting as seeing the
Beatles in their movie putting their
songs together that to me would be a
piece of History I would like to see
foreign